>> Laura: FRIGHTENING PROPOSALS
EMERGING FROM A U.N. PANEL OVER
THE WEEKENDMENT NOT ONLY DOES
THE SO-CALLED UNITED NATIONS
GLOBAL COMPACT FOR SAFE, ORDERLY
AND REGULAR MIGRATION WANT TO
MAKE IMMIGRATION A UNIVERSAL
HUMAN RIGHT, THEY WANT TO MAKE
IT A CRIME FOR MEDIA OUTLETS TO
ALLOW FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
CRITICISM AGAINST MIGRATION.
WATCH.
>> CRITICISM OF MIGRATION WILL
BECOME A CRIMINAL OFFENSE, AND
MEDIA OUTLETS -- AND THAT ALSO
CONCERNS YOU -- TAGIVE ROOM TO
CRITICISM OF MIGRATION CAN BE
SHUT DOWN.
>> Laura: HERE NOW IS SOMEONE
WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT THIS THAN
THE AVERAGE JOE, I WOULD SAY,
THIS DIMINISHED E.U. TODAY IS
NIGEL FARAGE, OF THE PREXIT
MOVEMENT THAT RAISED IMMIGRATION
DESTROYING THE FIBER OF THE
U.K., THANKS FOR STAYING UP LATE
FOR US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
IS THERE A CHANCE THAT WITH THIS
GLOBAL COMPACT ON MIGRATION THAT
THIS ACTUALLY COULD COME TO PASS
THAT THIS TYPE OF CRITICISM OF
MIGRATION COULD BE CRIMINALIZED?
>> YOU WERE QUITE RIGHT TO SAY
THAT WHAT THE U.N. WANTS TO DO
IS MAKE IMMIGRATION A HUMAN
RIGHT, WHAT IT ALSO WANTS TO DO
IS MAKE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
LEGAL BY DEFINING A REFUGEE AS
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO MOVE
BETWEEN COUNTRIES.
SO BASICALLY WHAT IT WANTS TO DO
IS TO MAKE US ALL GLOBAL
CITIZENS AND GOVERNMENTS ARE
GOING TO THIS NEXT WEEK.
MANY WILL SIGN UP TO IT WITHOUT
EVER CONSULTING THEIR OWN
PEOPLE, BUT YOU ARE QUITE RIGHT.
THE MOST WORRYING PART IS THE
SECTION ON THE MEDIA WHERE IT
SAYS VERY CLEARLY THAT MEDIA
OUTLETS WHO ARE INTOLERANT,
CRITICAL, XENOPHOBIC OR RACIST
IN THEIR CRITICISM OF MASS
MIGRATION -- AS SOON AS YOU
START TO DEFINE PEOPLE LIKE THAT
YOU'RE GETTING INTO TERRITORY
WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE DEFINED AS
COMMITTING HATE CRIMES.
THEY WANT TO MAKE IT -- THEY
ACTUALLY WANT TO MAKE IT ILLEGAL
TO CRITICIZE OPEN-DOOR
IMMIGRATION.
IS IT ACTUALLY GOING TO WORK?
THANKFULLY, THE U.N. ITSELF
DOESN'T HAVE LEGAL POWER, BUT --
>> Laura: NIGEL, DOESN'T IT ALSO
OPERATE AS KIND OF A FRAMEWORK
FOR INTERNATIONAL HUMAN RIGHTS
CASES?
IT ENDS UP BEING A FRAMEWORK
THAT, UNDER A DIFFERENT SUPREME
COURT IN THIS COUNTRY COULD BE
REFERENCED?
THERE ARE A LOT OF JUSTICES WHO
BELIEVE THAT REFERENCING FOREIGN
LAW IS OK WHICH, OF COURSE, IT'S
NOT THE WAY IT'S DONE IN OUR
COUNTRY -- SADLY, IT'S BEEN DONE
IN THE PAST -- SO THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
IT BECOMES ANOTHER INTERNATIONAL
NORM AND CLIMATE CHANGE IS ONE
THING.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE, BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S A
NORM, SO IF YOU -- WE DO A LOT
OF STUFF ON MIGRATION.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION ISSUE FOR
YEARS SO TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ON SOCIAL WELFARE IN
THE UNITED STATES, A SURVEY
TODAY, ABOUT 61% ON SOME TYPE OF
SOCIAL PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED,
PERHAPS, HATEFUL.
>> YEAH.
HERE I AM IN LONDON.
AS WE SPEAK, THERE ARE A
THOUSAND POLICE OFFICERS IN
LONDON WHO JUST INVESTIGATE HATE
CRIME AND THE DEFINITIONS OF
WHAT HATE CRIME GET BROADER AND
BROADER.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY THE U.N.
TO MAKE ANY CRITICISM OF MASS
MIGRATION SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED CRIMINAL, AND
EFFECTIVELY WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
IS THEY WILL FAVOR MEDIA OUTLETS
THAT PROMOTE THEIR IDEAS
MATERIALLY.
THEY'RE EVEN TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING MEDIA OUTLETS THAT
SUPPORT THEIR VIEW.
I'M BEING SERIOUS.
BELIEVE ME, I HAVE SEEN THIS
MYSELF IN BRUSSELS BECAUSE THE
EUROPEAN UNION -- THAT IS THE
SORT OF PROTOTYPE FOR THE
GLOBALISTS, AND THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION ACTUALLY GIVE MONEY
TO MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROMOTE THEIR VIEWS, AND
INCREASINGLY DEMONIZE THOSE THAT
TAKE A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW,
AND YOU ARE RIGHT, THE
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL COURT.
AREAS LIKE THAT CAN START TO
MAKE JUDGMENTS IN THESE AREAS
THAT WILL, YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT,
BE REFERENCED BY NATIONAL
COURTS.
>> Laura: THEY MARGINALIZE
VOICES.
YOU SEE THIS HAPPEN ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, ON TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
YOUTUBE CHANNELS, THEY'RE MAKING
JUDGMENT CALLS ON WHO AND WHO IS
NOT PART OF THE ACCEPTABLE CLUB,
NIGEL, THE GRAND DAMME OF
MIGRATION, ANGELA MERKEL FROM A
WEEK AND A HALF AGO OR SO.
LET'S WATCH.
[SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> Laura: YOU'RE ON SATELLITE.
UNLESS YOUR GERMAN REALLY GOOD
IT'S BASICALLY THIS IS A RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO STAND UP FOR THE
RIGHT OF REFUGEES.
I BELIEVE IN STANDING UP FOR
REFUGEES BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT EVERY COUNTRY'S BORDER HAS
TO REMAIN OPEN IF A GLOBAL
ENTITY LIKE THE U.N. SAYS, "OK,
YOU'VE GOT TO DO IT" WHETHER
IT'S TO THE 7,000 PEOPLE IN
TIJUANA OR ANY OTHER GROUP.
>> LET'S REMEMBER WHAT A REFUGEE
IS.
1951 DEFINITION OF WHAT A
REFUGEE IS AND IT'S A PERSON IN
FEAR OF THEIR LIFE OR THEIR
LIBERTY AS A RESULT OF THEIR
RACE, THEIR RELIGION, THEIR
VIEWS, THEIR ORIENTATION.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE CROSSED THE
MEDITERRANEAN OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS ENCOURAGED BY
ANGELA MERKEL WERE REFUGEES.
THEY WEREN'T.
THEY WERE ECONOMIC MIGRANTS
COMING FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
USING THE OPPORTUNITY OF THE
HUGE STUPIDITY MADE BY ANGELA
MERKEL, I GENUINELY BELIEVE THAT
CHRISTIANS LIVING IN IRAQ AND
COUNTRIES LIKE THAT WHO HAVE
LITERALLY GOT NOWHERE TO GO,
THEY QUALIFY AS GENUINE
REFUGEES, BUT YOU CANNOT OPEN
THE DOOR TO MASS MILLIONS, AND
SUDDENLY PRETEND THAT'S OK, AND
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE U.N.
ARE TRYING TO DO NEXT WEEK.
THEY'RE TRYING TO BAIL OUT
ANGELA MERKEL AND THE OTHER
POLITICIANS WHO HAVE MADE THESE
HUGE MISTAKES AND I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT WHAT MRS. MERKEL OUGHT
TO DO RATHER THAN DEFENDING HER
JUDGMENT IS TO APOLOGIZE TO
MILLIONS OF GERMAN PEOPLE FOR
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING THE
NATURE OF A CULTURE OF THE TOWNS
AND CITIES IN WHICH PEOPLE LIVE
WITHOUT EVER ASKING THE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: SWEDEN IS SEEING ITS
POPULIST MOVEMENT.
WE SAW THE LAST ELECTION.
ANDALUSIA.
MACRON.